so
so so then are you also if we're saying
automation is no matter what coming
we're there automation no matter what is
coming
let's just say minimum wages you know it
is what it is
pick a number leave it there uh are you
also you know
the one word that create a lot of
momentum this last time around was ubi
you kept hearing our ubi ubi ubi ubi
with
andrew yang and he says well milton
friedman tried to do it he talked about
ubi even though he was milton friedman's
idea was negative you know was a
completely different system you kind of
briefly talked about it today
he says well mlk wanted to do this
what's wrong with us doing ubi
right if automation is inevitable and
we're going in that direction do you
think
ubi is also inevitable you know
the basic income concept where you give
a payment
will hurt jobs output and employment
that is not my way of solving the world
of what i would not
do and let me just say it really
explicitly patrick
milton refriedman's minimum wage the ubi
all of these say
if you earn higher incomes you get taxed
on that
from the base level on that is a
disincentive all the way there
uh i would what i would do very simply
is i'd do a low rate broad-based flat
tax
just like i did for jerry brown when he
ran for president
in 1992 you replace all federal
income taxes all federal taxes of all
sorts
with two low rate uh low rate
broad-based taxes you want the lowest
rate to provide people with the least
incentives
to evade or void or otherwise not report
taxable income and you want the broader
space so they have the least place
they can stick their income and thus
avoid paying taxes
if you replaced all federal taxes with
two
low-rate broad-based tax one on
value-added or what republicans call
business net sales and one on personal
unadjusted gross income
so it's on the first dollar to the last
dollar you could match
all federal revenues today all of them
with two flat rate taxes on 12 of 12
no payroll taxes no medicare no medicaid
no
excise taxes no corporate taxes no
personal income taxes no capital gains
taxes no death taxes
all federal taxes gone except for sin
taxes which are a teeny tiny portion
all of that could be replaced by this
without even assuming a laffer curve
i mean that's what jerry brown ran down
we went from eighth in the race in the
democratic primary in 92
to second in the race and i think we
would have won the race
if jerry hadn't picked his vice
president the way he did
uh if we did that i mean you would have
that low rate can you imagine
you pay you're paid a hundred bucks
patrick and uh what you have to do is
send an 87
uh send in 13 uh bucks and you get to
keep 87.
or better yet your employer gives you 87
and they send in 13 before you
you don't even have to file a tax return
for goodness sakes i mean that's what we
should have as taxes
so we have a complete if you want to
help people
who don't have income who are in some
sense dire circumstances okay
write him a check you know what does a
what does an income
tax credit do to a mother with kids who
doesn't file a tax return
nothing you know what you want to do is
write them a check
so they get the check clear and you're
not confusing the tax system with a
spending system so if you like this sort
of short clip from an interview i did
click over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye